welcome to this video playing um Malik
saw from Israel we have Queens gambit
triangle it is playing a five this is
not see too often from good players so
rather well known that black gets a
quite quite miserable position after
that so surprising to see that okay just
cancel the problem is at the end he's
some suffering from the bed Stonewall
bishop on d7 and tim i always have this
e 5 square and potential pressure down
the down the e-file I'd like to do is to
to get in f3 here to open up the eval
yeah okay this is this is okay
yeah this is a case where doubled pawns
are not really a problem in fact the
double pawns are really nice for white
here the double def porn is very good in
controlling the porn square cm default
okay so he's preparing for c 5k
interesting
yeah I can I can intensify of the
pressure against the six bond but my
night only five which is nicely placed
from a theoretical point of view it's
always just blocking okay I try to
reroute the Queen here and I can play c5
this was my intention
hmm strange that he allowed that this is
a really nice now isn't it they are just
now doubling on the B file yeah I feel
after you allowed me to play c4 c5 his
pawns are eternally fixed on light
squares
maybe you should take a play a five I
play it but it's so bad I take care take
with the take with the pawn
okay so should I play Queen a6 intending
rugby seven now if it's not bad
hmm why is this even playable Quincy six
don't know e six is also having you
cannot move the Queen anywhere like
Queen a five or something so I only see
Queen takes c6 and this just loses the
house
okay if I take with the I probably just
take with the a pawn it's that some some
trick if I take with the rook okay 8
yeah I don't have a way to protect the
pawn on c5 some probably take here some
now okay eight if i move the night
before yesterday's 95 silly trick and
can't believe that this isn't isn't
really winning but probably it isn't or
how to believe ready
hmm
yeah the check on c6 isn't working at
all okay what can you do
really strange
yeah I still should have something with
the night on c5 event and this is this
kind of things but why wasn't this
technically winning quite strange
yeah they to pawn but threatening 95 at
Teague once you form now I can actually
move the pawn let's try that
so interesting tactics EMP 78 now at 95
and I'd be seven was even stronger night
beside this was was would have been even
stronger
okay I get a second chance
okay 496 checking is seven and p7 just
bishop asics check time money yeah I am
too little time check check
check check check yep and it's a matter
of time again white forfeits on time
yeah yeah I didn't manage at the end on
time it's just just a piece of here
before for nothing check check I hope
that oops yeah oops i hope that jam this
is what would would work take on on d3
to make quick moves now 44 seconds but
his king is just it's just quick am
couldn't i couldn't calculate that but
what really is really red I mean why
isn't white winning here I mean 97 it's
just cannot believe that yeah it doesn't
seem to win out right now I can take
with the rook and play rugby 5 yeah I
saw that but it looked really unnatural
okay this this also keeps on some edge
here but yeah I just allowed me to
promote the pawn basically 97 I got the
second second chance now with Chang
multiple ways I window the GPS but okay
can play play better here but yeah this
this is very strong actually intending
95 this is much better I'll in the deep
or now for from your compensation yeah
but I was down to nine seconds i had
spent far too much time in
so it's still it's the fields we had
that you should get out of this this
position which is just just like
dystrophy there's something better yeah
well nights Quincy six is good but it's
just not as good as I thought that it
would be this is the probably the best
way to play yeah it just seemed strange
to me it doesn't look harmonious to to
place the rook into this but the
computer is just check unimpressed as
usual yeah this is excellent for white
no no question yeah I didn't I didn't
find that and what I had in the game
with with this really wasn't wasn't so
great I mean it's nice and better for
white but it really should be a win not
not nice and better this is just just
not not very good for black maybe I'm
yeah but it'sit's I need to add I must
fight this this one variation that would
be five it just it's just a matter of
precision to find exactly that which I
didn't do and then I had lost so much
time while trying to exploit this that I
couldn't couldn't catch up at the end
this is ok for black the only managed to
get into trouble again but this is ok
for luck ok thanks for watching